RETO MEIER: All the
great speed improvements
of Android 2.0
and everything you
need to be able to take full
advantage of the Android N
Developer Preview, plus a bunch
of bug fixes and stability
improvements.
I'm Reto Meier, it's
Android Tool Time time,
and this is Android Studio 2.1.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Installing the
Android N Preview SDK
requires Android Studio 2.1.
As well as N-specific
bug fixes, it also
supports the N Developer
Preview emulator, system images.
It also allows you to
use the new Jack compiler
but note that Jack doesn't
currently support Instant Run.
Jack does support many
Java 8 language features
such as lambda expressions.
Our lambda implementation
uses anonymous classes,
making their use
backwards compatible.
If you target
Android N, Jack also
supports default and
static interface methods,
repeatable annotations,
and method references,
though they are not
backward compatible.
Android Studio 2.1
includes speed improvements
to Instant Run, making
it significantly faster.
For instance, to reduce
compilation time,
the incremental Java
[INAUDIBLE] feature is now
enabled by default. If you've
allocated enough memory
to the Gradle Daemon, we also
enabled dexing in process
by default, which performs
dexing within the build process
rather than a separate,
external VM process.
Aside from these features,
Android Studio 2.1
also includes a number of
bug fixes and stability
improvements, especially
for users with the Android N
Preview SDK installed.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You know, the
last time Android Studio did
a point update with
mainly bug fixes,
it was right before
a major release.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
Yeah, I guess you're right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And right
before a pretty big developer
conference and isn't
Google I/O coming up?
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
May 18.
It's just a coincidence, though.
I wouldn't read
too much into it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sure, right.
So can we look in the box?
RETO MEIER: I'd really
prefer it if you didn't.
Upgrade to Android Studio 2.1
to play with the new Android N
Developer Preview,
get faster Instant Run
and take advantage of a bunch
of bug fixes and stability
improvements.
This is Android Studio 2.1, and
this is Android Tool Time time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]